jaras merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france
alors afin de lutter contre la pandémie
je les dis de nombreux pays ont mis en
place des systèmes de surveillance
parfois utilisant l'intelligence
artificielle quels sont ils ces systèmes
alors vous savez c'est un c'est un vrai
souci qui existent de savoir qu'est ce
qu'on doit privilégier la santé des
individus ou ou la surveillance et là on
voit que les six la une les nouvelles
technologies permettent de de tracer les
individus et de manière non anonyme et c
c'est ça qui aujourd'hui pose un
véritable problème et qui fait que l'on
dit que les nouvelles technologies sont
en eux posent des difficultés sur les
libertés individuelles puisque les
drones nos smartphones nous tourner tous
nos moyens de qui nous suivent à la
trace vont pouvoir permettre de nous
contrôler et de savoir si oui ou non
nous sommes contents jeu ou pas nous
pouvons circuler ou pas alors c'est un
constat il ya augmentation de la
surveillance de masse vous êtes avocat
est ce que c'est légal alors nous avons
en europe le règlement général de la
protection des données qui impose que
avant toute mise en place d'un système
de contrôle des individus cela ne peut
pas se faire à leur insu il faut qu'il
donne un consentement
ceci dit il y a eu une loi la loi du 23
mars 2020 qui a permis au premier
ministre de prendre des paires et des
prérogatives exorbitantes en matière de
restriction des libertés sans réels
pouvoirs du contrôle c'est quand même
une phrase qui est transitoire en afin
d'assurer la santé et la sécurité
publiques et donc nous sommes dans ce
cadre là où nous sommes dans un système
ici de dérogation qui est suivie
également par d'autres pays qui ont un
qui ont fait la même chose et je pense
notamment à à singapour qui si vous
voulez prépare le système du contact
tracking tracts racing qui n'est pas qui
s'il devient obligatoire pour la sortie
du confinement posera deux
véritable problème en matière de
libertés individuelles oui moi l'univers
en gros c'est ce qu'on nous martèle oui
alors le problème qu'il y à toujours
derrière ça c'est là on est dans un état
de d'urgence c'est une période
transitoire à limiter un mois le
problème c'est que les gouvernants
lorsqu'il pleut et prennent si vous
voulez le contrôle des usagers ils ont
tendance à après à vouloir le conserver
on en connaît quand même pas mal de
choses en matière de terrorisme
on avait vu la lutte sur le terrorisme
il ya après des résidus d'autant plus
que l'on ne sait pas pendant combien de
temps va durer la surveillance des
personnes pour ne pas contaminer les
autres
et donc là il ya ce souci de sécurité
qui est demandé par les citoyens et puis
le côté de nos libertés individuelles et
je pense également que l'on voit qu'il
ya une érosion en fait de liberté
individuelle mais nous sommes en guerre
et donc ça peut justifier un certain
nombre de restrictions
gérard à sa merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous étiez en
direct avec nous sur arte france ô est
avocat spécialisé en droit des nouvelles
technologies et de la propriété
intellectuelle